[Musique]
leur sang a été complètement drainer les
yeux de la victime masculine était
retenu ouverts par des aiguilles la
victime féminine était dans ses bras
quelqu'un utilise toutes petites filles
trouvent le gîte ont pris une carte
postale a été envoyé un journal à paris
une autre à hambourg et une à budapest
il annonce son arrivée dans une ville
avec une carte postale
pourquoi il les a placés comme ça il
veut transmettre message c'est là le
baiser de rodin dante et virgile en
enfer saturne dévorant un de ses fils
ils ont découvert un cinquième corps
je crois qu'il ma frite et précis est
bien préparé c'est ptet pas vous avez
exactement quatre jours pour empêcher un
mur
je vais devoir y répondre par moi même
je vous le déconseille fortement
vous avez eu votre chance je suis
policier plus 30 ans le type de crime
que fait ce meurtrier est très
spécifique
il est extrêmement difficile à profiler
mais les monstres restait toujours des
nôtres peu importe ce qu'on fait pour
les calmer
semble logique de manière vraiment tordu
l'amour la souffrance la mort
ils ont pas encore terminé
l'art est une blessure transformé en
gruyère
[Musique]
regarde et me sentir pendant toute la
durée du vol aller à la vôtre à l'apôtre
6 h au plus fin
et donc j'ai encore est en fait baby
chanteur fait j'avais ce cas là des
fauteuils et encore mais d'enfants en
fait je crois que j'ai jamais été
amoureux n'avaient pas encore trouvé
pourquoi j'ai en plus j'aimerais qu'on
dise rien ce que je suis une pure ce que
je crois que je fais rien
disons juste contre nous les choses dans
sa phase postérieure
[Musique]
je fonctionne pas entre nous on peut
savoir ce qui se passe si jacquard coeur
à rire
bonjour et bas bonjour monsieur arthuis
très belle je viens à bord de l'avion
celui sur qui tu as des vertus dont il
est le numéro un
la boîte tout ce que je vous ai dit
j'aurais adoré savons ce que ça fait
d'avoir pu
reste secret je me demandais si vous
voudriez ça vous dirait continent
semblent principe numéro un ne pas
montrer ce que vous ressentez un et
houriez avoir n'importe quelle femme
peut-être mais c'est vos cheveux vous
êtes assez méfiant il est plus que
connor m'aidait pas il s'intéresse à moi
les api et a confié les choses a produit
non
alors comme ça tu te fait stopper par
jaccar peuvent ranger vos affaires quoi
est-ce que vous renvoyez gbq si milliers
de vies
sûrement que des secrets sont plus
importants que les miens non c'est archi
faux de dire ça je t'assure je veux plus
jamais parler avec 32 voix août au point
de susciter ou à raison j'aurais dû
partager bien plus de chez eux
on devrait toujours tout se dire
lorsqu'on fait la rencontre de quelqu'un
je vais une circoncision
[Musique]
on veut bien nous voir
mais pas nous écouter nous sommes le
footing c'est notre j'arrive je sais que
vous êtes spéciale
dis moi quel est le plan conserver ce
soir
le monde doit savoir ce qui se passe
est-ce que tu as une princesse tête bien
c'est vrai on brosse mois le super
prince charmant est de retour ouais
[Musique]
l'enregistrement a commencé et
continuera jusqu'à la fin
qu'oslo est un repris de justice c'est
aussi un informateur pour le fbi
on a un acheteur tu t'achètes tout ce
que tu as cannes
[Musique]
des flics si ces mecs le découvre tu es
un homme mort tout s'est tu vas avoir
une chance de s'en sortir
je vais te la donner dans quelques
secondes project
mettez vous met en évidence ce mauvais
pour les affaires
c'est ainsi qu'a dit qu'il avait tiré
quand le flic avait pointé sans flingue
sur toi
tu dois maintenant le prix de ta vie un
veau était cas combien tu évalues ta vie
tu auras ta condition retrouver en
prison alors c'est quelqu'un de réussir
à y faire entrer de la drogue à toi je
veux arrêter vous fait que le général
vous demande un trafic de fentanyl
planifié de l'extérieur pour inonder les
prisons bouclera richard klimek avis si
vous en apporter la preuve
vous serez libre
sais tu retournes à présent temps
sortira plus j'enquête sur la mort d'un
homme dont j'étais très proche
on ne peut pas laisser ce lieutenant
découvrir qu'un informateur du fbi a été
présent pendant l'assassinât de l'un des
siens vous voulez voir votre agence
affronter le plus gros département de
police du monde
on aime bien la bagarre à quoi vous
pensez
planté le même famille on s'est engagé
auprès de lui on lui a promis certaines
choses je n'ai pas d'enfant je souffrais
tellement c'est un jour de leur arrivée
à ma mère et je te soutiens aucun vis tu
perds tu as ma parole
le préfet
moi je suis le bout rond et je suis là
pour te passer la corde au cou
vous ressortirez pas cette fois
ça a assez duré
surprise
[Musique]
je
tayara
anna pyatykh
ce pas
comme auxerre
chaque être